c'est sûrement l'élection qui fait le
moins parler d'elle
l'enjeu des sénatoriales n'est pourtant
pas négligeable
le palais du luxembourg renouvelle près
de la moitié de ses membres cette année
1449 candidats se disputent les 172
sièges remise en jeu dans 59
départements et quatre collectivités
d'outre-mer sénat est renouvelable par
moitié tous les trois ans les sénateurs
ils sont élus pour un mandat de six ans
la particularité de cette élection
elle tient à son mode de scrutin ce ne
sont pas les français qui participent
directement mais leurs représentants
cette fois un collège de 87 mille grands
électeurs parmi eux figurent députés et
sénateurs conseillers régionaux et
départementaux et 95% de délégués des
conseils municipaux
c'est d'ailleurs pour cette raison qu'on
dit que l'issue des sénatoriales devrait
être une réplique de celle des
municipales à ceux qui s'interrogent
encore aujourd'hui de savoir qui a gagné
les municipales
nous le verrons aux sénatoriales le
résultat des municipales peut nous
mettre en difficulté dans deux ou trois
départements comme la gironde mais vu la
masse de petites et moyennes villes le
corps électoral n'a pas beaucoup changé
pour nous comprenait la droite qui est
largement majoritaire au palais du
luxembourg le restera après le scrutin
et grâce notamment à une alliance entre
les républicains et l'union centriste
gérard larcher de son côté devrait
logiquement conserver la présidence du
sénat à gauche le parti socialiste
compte pour l'heure 71 sièges et devrait
rester le deuxième groupe le plus
important de la chambre haute du
parlement
l'enjeu majeur de ce scrutin c'est de
voir si un groupe écologiste au pourrait
renaître au sénat après sa disparition
en 2017 pour cela europe ecologie les
verts doit atteindre le seuil des 10
élus nécessaires à la constitution d'un
groupe au sein du parti
on estime que le défi devrait être
largement relevé d'autant que plusieurs
grandes villes de france comme lyon
bordeaux et strasbourg sont passés au
vert aux dernières municipales
c'est une bataille qui est passé sous
les radars
de l'opinion mais on l'a en vue ici et
là on pourrait venir renforcer les
troupes au sénat et retrouver un groupe
politique
qu'en est il de la république en marche
le parti présidentiel s'est pris une
claque aux municipales une gifle aux
législatives partielles
françois patriat chef de file des
sénateurs macro nist est lui même en
danger en côte d'or
l'existence du groupe et l'hérault m
n'est pas menacée pour autant puisque 13
des sièges qu'ils occupent ne sont pas
remises en jeu
les sénatoriales devrait traduire le peu
de crédibilité territoriale de la
république en marche qui après trois
années n'a pas réussi à creuser son
sillon en france mais cela ne préjuge
pas du résultat de 2022
ce son et les rer et le rn qui ont le
plus perdu au municipal
ils devraient donc perdre aussi beaucoup
pour les sénatoriales preuve que les
français ne veulent pas pour la
présidentielle du face à face entre
emmanuel macron et marine le pen le
parti de marine le pen lui joue sa
survie au sein de l'hémicycle
en 2014 le rassemblement national avait
réussi pour la première fois à faire
élire deux de ses représentants au
palais du luxembourg et stéphane ravier
maire du 7e secteur de marseille et
david rachline maire de fréjus qui a
démissionné en 2017 pour cause de cumul
de mandats un an plus tard sa
successeure préfère quitter le parti
résultat leur elle ne dispose plus que
d'un seul siège lui même fortement
menacée après la contre-performance de
stéphane ravier aux municipales si ce
scrutin n'est pas le plus populaire il
peut néanmoins servir à démontrer les
tendances politiques actuelles